[Music]
well hi i'm forest brazil i'm a cloud
builder and educator and i work here at
google cloud
you know over the years as i talk to
members of the cloud community i
constantly get asked versions of the
same question which is
how do i get into a cloud or devops
engineering role from what we might call
a traditional it career so you might be
a windows server admin or a dba you
might be racking and stacking servers or
working in a noc but you're doing all
that in the context of a traditional
data center not in the cloud i actually
started my career that way as well doing
many of the things i just mentioned
before moving into a cloud role several
years ago
and in this video we're going to lay out
a path for how you can make that
transition from a legacy i.t career to a
role where you get to build on google
cloud services so let's dive right in
okay the first question you're going to
want to ask yourself is why what's the
point of choosing a cloud role when
maybe i already have a career that's
going fine i'm in a good groove and an
easy answer might be that cloud market
is very hot right now uh take a look at
these numbers here look at these
salaries associated with google cloud
certifications this data is from global
knowledge and to be clear i didn't
cherry pick this those top two numbers
you see there for google cloud certs
those aren't just the top two paying
google cloud certs they aren't just the
top two paying cloud certs in the world
those are the top two certs anywhere in
it as of 2021. just to be very clear you
know and i know that certifications are
not the whole story here
it's very difficult to get hired into a
cloud role unless you can show some
hands-on experience working with cloud
even if you've already got experience
working in a traditional i.t role so how
are you going to get that experience
and this is kind of a unique problem for
you right because you may not be able to
just like go back to square one and
start again with schooling or something
like that you've already got a career
maybe you've got a family you can't take
two steps back to take one step forward
you've gotta find a path to this cloud
role that's going to enable you to
augment your skills without starting
over so here's what i recommend that you
do we're going to cover three steps to
your cloud career coming out of
traditional i.t we might call them the
three it to cloud commandments the first
one is that you need to exploit your
unfair advantage what do i mean by this
you'll hear this term used a lot in the
startup world where founders talk about
finding the one thing they do better
than anybody else and just really
doubling down on that well
if you're watching this video your
unfair advantage may be that you're
already employed in some form of tech
i.t is in your blood a little bit as you
were and that's going to give you a
tremendous advantage relative to other
people who are trying to break into
cloud for the first time but you've got
to access this advantage and that's
going to likely look like taking
advantage of the existing opportunities
you have to get close to cloud in your
professional context cloud builds on
fundamentals that have been around for a
long time compute networking storage all
forms of access control these are things
that you understand that you've got some
context with so why not figure out how
to cloudify those existing skills how to
turn those skills into cloud versions of
themselves there's three steps to doing
this the first step is simply to build
the thing that you already know so let's
say that you're a sql server dba like i
used to be okay well let's see if you
can stand up a sql server in google
cloud you can use the console for this
you can point and click around the point
is just to transfer your knowledge of
standing up a sql server on the old data
center in the virtual machine
to standing it up in google cloud second
step once you've done that go ahead and
automate that same process so now
instead of pointing and clicking instead
of using click ops you're going to use
some form of automation you're going to
use something like terraform to automate
the standing up of that underlying
server you're going to use some
scripting or automation to make sure
that that sql server is initialized the
same way every time you're going to use
some form of source control right to
make sure that you keep track of all
that configuration and you're going to
use some sort of a ci cd pipeline we'd
assume to make sure that that code gets
from your laptop into the cloud the same
way every time without you touching it
in between
and then once you've done that the third
step is to try to reproduce the same
idea using managed cloud services so
instead of sql server you might say hey
i wonder if i could achieve the same
results using google cloud sql or maybe
google cloud spanner give it a try it's
going to expand the circle of what you
already know
to encompass the cloud now on the other
hand you may see things happening in
your company that are cloud related that
you are not part of and don't feel like
you have the ability to access right now
there might be a cloud engineering
department over there across the hall
and you see what they're doing and it
looks really cool but it's just not
related to your current job at all in
that case i would recommend go talk to
those people see if you can sit down and
have lunch with them ask to pick their
brain ask for some mentorship buy them
coffee max out your access to colleagues
who do what you would like to do that's
part of your unfair advantage right now
is having access to those people and to
their problems who knows uh worst case
you're going to learn a lot about what
they do you're going to get great advice
from them on where you need to focus
your skilling up best case they might
have an internal role opening up soon
that you are top of mind for just
leverage the heck out of those
connections only good things are going
to happen but and this is important if
those opportunities aren't coming to you
naturally you don't need to sit around
forever and wait for them ultimately
it's not your team that's responsible
for the trajectory of your career it's
not your employer it is you who's
responsible for it so if the cloud
opportunities are not coming to you you
need to go out and get them and that
brings us to our second i t to cloud
commandment and the second commandment
is to boost targeted skills and i'm
being very deliberate in saying it that
way because again as we've said you may
not have time to kind of burn the house
down and start from square one
with going back to school and building
up every skill from scratch you've got
to figure out where your gaps are and
you've got to make very intentional
targeted improvements to those gaps
there are four areas that you can dive
into here
and the first is you have to learn to
code there's a reason that people who
come from software development
backgrounds tend to find it much easier
to get into cloud than people who come
from traditional i.t backgrounds and
that is because code is a non-negotiable
if you want to become a cloud engineer
you're not able to just point and click
or use the gui to manage things anymore
you have to be able to automate if
you're going to keep up with the massive
scale of a cloud environment so if you
don't have a cloud or if you don't have
a language already know try python it's
pretty ubiquitous in cloud environments
but code is the barrier and code is the
bridge to a cloud engineering role
you don't necessarily have to be a leak
code person you don't have to be
crunching algorithms that's not going to
come up a lot in a cloud interview but
you do need to be able to perform basic
automation and data manipulation tasks
that do come up every day in a cloud
role learn to code second thing learn
the basics of linux and networking and
this may be something that feels more
core to what you've been doing in it and
that's great but you will need to
remember the linux file system basic
linux commands you'll want to make sure
you understand the fundamentals of
containerization and of course you'll
want to know the core networking
concepts like the iprotocol and all the
other protocols that layer on top of it
dns subnets all that good stuff again
some of this may be more familiar to you
you've touched it before there's lots of
courses and
videos out there you can use as a
refresher but
the these are not going away in the
cloud they're only becoming more
important because so many systems are
built on top of them and you will want
to make sure that you're fresh on those
when you go into an interview so code
linux and networking third thing if you
want to get a cloud job believe it or
not you actually should know a little
bit about the cloud itself in this video
we're talking about google cloud so how
are you going to learn about google
cloud i recommend google cloud skills
boost it's google's own platform for
training you on google cloud when you
can check out the infrastructure
modernization track there it's got a
nice combination of hands-on learning
and certification prep yeah we talked
about how certifications maybe have some
limitations but i do think it's
important for you to have a google cloud
certification if you're trying to
transition into a google cloud role and
given where you are in your career i
would recommend you go after a
professional level certification like
the google cloud professional architect
it's going to be difficult but it's
going to signal that you're serious that
you're a pro on this subject and given
where you are i think that's going to be
necessary for you
code linux and networking go deep on
google cloud and then finally you're
going to want to have some familiarity
with open source tooling whatever cloud
provider you go to work on there's going
to be certain tools that pop up in
almost every shop doing automation i've
already said it terraform's probably
going to be involved in some way working
with containers kubernetes probably
going to be on the table these are open
source they travel they're portable
between clouds take some time to learn
those use something like kubernetes the
hard way from kelsey hightower to figure
out what kubernetes is how it works what
problems it's good for solving
with terraform learn how to deploy some
cloud services and this brings us to a
piece of advice that should tie together
all four of the areas i just mentioned
which is before you start interviewing
you'll want to build a couple of
hands-on projects what do i mean by that
take these cloud skills you've learned
and actually create something that's
real that's live that's out there in the
world that you can use as a story during
an interview
i'm very serious about this for a couple
years i've been running a community
initiative called the cloud resume
challenge it's free you can do it on
google cloud and it'll get you up close
and personal with almost everything i
just mentioned give you something that
you can talk about in an interview you
can check that out at
cloudresumechallenge.dev
okay so let's say you've exploited your
unfair advantage as much as you can
you've found your skills gaps you've
plugged them as much as you can and now
here you are in interviews and you're
still not getting traction on that cloud
engineer or cloud architect role that
you wanted don't worry this brings us to
the third of our i.t to cloud
commandments which is you may need to
take a stepping stone role not moving
backward but taking an intermediate step
before you get to your end destination
there's a lot of different roles you can
take that'll move you closer to the
cloud i'm not going to be exhaustive
here in what i mentioned but i'm going
to list several that i've seen be
helpful to a lot of people number one
and this is the first thing i would try
you can look for an i.t admin role that
has a little bit more of a hybrid aspect
to it so while cloud qualifications are
not a must in order for you to get hired
you know when you look at that company's
environment that they have some stuff on
premises and they have some stuff in the
cloud and either they're going to be
moving the on-premises stuff to the
cloud or they're going to have both of
these environments around for a while
and so even though you're probably
getting hired based on your traditional
qualifications you know that you're
probably going to be migrating to the
cloud right along with these workloads
so you've got some cloud advancement
some cloud skilling up that's built into
your professional role we talked about
wanting to get that with you know
exploiting your unfair advantage
internally but this would be looking for
a company where you can do that if you
can't do it where you are right now
so look into that hybrid i.t admin role
second thing you might want to check out
you might look into what we might call a
cloud engineering adjacent role so
there's a lot of companies google does
this a lot of their partners do this
that have these roles called technical
account manager or tam technical program
manager or tpm these are roles that are
not technically engineering roles but
they are very technical a lot of times
deep traditional it experience is a big
plus when you're getting hired into
these roles and you'll be hands on with
customers you'll be hands on with google
cloud solutions day in and day out these
can be a great way for you to transition
into a true cloud engineering role over
time
third thing and this might be more
interesting if you're a little earlier
in your career it would be to become a
cloud support engineer at google cloud
or another of the major cloud providers
this is kind of like the help desk of
the cloud but instead of turning
people's laptops on and off you'll be
helping them troubleshoot cloud
administration issues great way to get
up close and personal with a huge
variety of cloud tasks you'll get very
hands-on and it will set you up for more
advanced roles in the future
and then finally and this may surprise
you there actually can be a lot of value
to becoming a technical trainer believe
it or not teaching someone something is
still one of the best ways to learn the
thing i've seen a lot of people
especially in my time working at a-cloud
guru and pluralsight make this fluid
career transition back and forth between
training and being a hands-on cloud
engineer it actually does work it's
interesting to try now remember there's
no law saying that if you do take one of
these intermediate positions that you
are stuck in it for three to four years
i mean this could be like a three to six
month slingshot opportunity for you
where you build some experience and then
you're ready to boomerang onto that
cloud engineering opportunity as soon as
it comes open remember what we said the
cloud market's very hot and as soon as
you start racking up this professional
experience those those inbound linkedin
connections are going to start rolling
in that's just reality in conclusion big
finish take an incremental path to the
cloud don't go backwards
instead maximize your current advantage
wherever you can take advantage of the
people that you're close to that
understand cloud take advantage of your
current professional work and cloudify
it wherever you can when that doesn't go
far enough try to boost targeted skills
to close the gaps and make yourself more
attractive to employers that includes
certification that includes hands-on
projects probably the most important
thing we've touched on in this video and
then finally if that's not quite getting
you to a true cloud engineering role
consider one of these hybrid or stepping
stone roles that will get you where you
want to be without taking you backwards
thank you so much for taking the time to
listen today i hope you like and
subscribe and make sure to join us next
time as we bring you more advice on
cracking the google cloud career
you